Hello, just waiting a couple of seconds to see if there's some additional people that join in here people might just kind of pop in when they can. So really we've got a lot of questions to go through today. So I hope everybody had an awesome weekend and happy Monday.
And I'm going to share the screen and we'll just start going through these questions. So hopefully everybody can see the screen here.
Just a reminder that here's kind of the weekly lineup of Zoom calls. So we obviously have the Monday Zoom call where it's question answer style with me and then Tuesdays for those of you who have not had a binder review yet.
We have an opportunity for you guys to come on to a Zoom call and we'll go through some binder specifics and get your binder questions answered. Then we have the Wednesdays Zoom call the typical Wednesdays Zoom call with Dr. Connors.
And then Thursdays, we will have Thursdays, we will have the two o'clock genetic review. These are all obviously central standard time. So if you guys want to screenshot that you certainly can and the genetic review binder review. So those are for people who have not already done that.
Okay. All right. So in another little reminder here to submit your Zoom call questions through the membership page.
They're in almost every page there at the top bar. There's the little blue button to submit a question button. It brings up this box where you would fill out your name email phone number and your Zoom questions.
So it's just a way to keep it all organized and in one place for us. So it's easy for us to just pull the questions from that format and therefore we're less likely to miss questions.
So thank you. We had a lot of questions come in today or over the weekend or since Dr. Connors call last last Wednesday.
So here is the first question, a question about the foot bath. So this person says they took off their toenail polish because she wondered if it was toxic.
So she said no nail polish on her toes for a while. I've noticed that in doing the foot baths, my toenails are starting to look yellow. I'm guessing that it is from soaking in what turns into pretty gross water.
The longer my feet are in them, is there something that I can do to prevent that are there nail polishes available that are okay and can cover it.
So as far as toenails becoming discolored, we have had a number of patients who have commented on that.
And yes, they're kind of relating it to the foot bath. Now, could it be from the high frequencies, possibly. Yeah, just your feet are in that water.
The goal is to get the high frequencies from the eye on pro wave array to enter through your body, through your feet.
Certainly, I don't know something with those higher frequencies could be causing some discoloration certainly could be from the minerals in the water as well. And yes, anybody who's done a foot bath knows that the water does get pretty gross and murky looking so it could be from that.
Sure. So there's no, you know, true answer on why it's happening other than, you know, it, it's happened to other people as well.
I don't know what you can do to prevent that other than potentially just really cleaning your nails after each foot bath. Maybe if you have like a little scrub brush thing and you can kind of really clean your nails afterwards.
And as far as nail polishes that might be less toxic. Yes, you certainly can, can find some nail polishes that are less toxic that could cover it. I pulled up or I took a screenshot of this website.
So this is the environmental working group and this is their skin deep database.
So you can certainly do a search for this or you can just type in this URL.
And this is a great tool. They have an app that you can download to your phone or like I said, you can just type it in on a computer and you can do searches for different products. So there's, it's a huge database of products.
The goal of this is to try to get less toxic products into the hands of people. So you can see on this bottom bar here. There's make up nails face somebody personal care fragrances.
So you can type in again, a brand and sometimes that brand or that exact product is within the database and it'll give you a score for each ingredient kind of a toxicity rating.
Sometimes they might not have the specific product, but you can look up the ingredients and the product that you're, you know, curious about, and you can get the score of the individual ingredients and see how they rate.
And certainly a great tool to use as you're trying to kind of transition your products nail polish. I did not type nail polish in there.
I did do kind of a quick Google search on just non toxic nail polish and there were definitely some brands that came up.
So you might just take one of those brands type it in the this app here and see what it comes up with as far as the toxicity rating and kind of make your decision based on that. So a good tool to have for everyone to utilize
The next question is there any testing that can be done on the mucus coming out of my breast.
The nipple is ulcerated and has been leaking various fluids for almost three years.
Doctors say the only test is a biopsy. I was previously concerned about a biopsy causing seating. Now the masses are so big and the ulceration so deep I don't know what to do.
So as far as I'm aware of there's not a specific test that could be done on the mucus itself.
Certainly this is a common thing that happens with breast cancer with a breast cancer diagnosis. Some in it's one of the, you know, kind of signs that something obviously is going on within the breast tissue if there's mucus coming out of the breast.
I don't know of a test that can be done specifically on the mucus.
Certainly there's other tests that you can do to kind of gauge where you're at as far as, you know, a tumor, you know, we've talked a lot about tumor marker tests and tracking that way. So, you know, those can be handy.
I'm not sure what you are looking to find out from a test.
You know, really a confirmed diagnosis. So this would be a symptom of a confirmed diagnosis. So I'm not sure what a specific test on the mucus would what type of information you're looking for.
Yes, we know that a biopsy can, you know, kind of spread. There is potential for it to spread cancer and so that is one of the reservations.
So really the question in any type of conventional testing is what with the results of a specific test, what would you do with that information.
So if you know you're not going to do any conventional care, then it's not really necessary for you to do conventional testing or scanning because it's not going to affect your care.
So if a test or scan would potentially, you know, change your mind, make you do some chemotherapy or maybe a procedure or surgery or who knows.
Then certainly yes, you can do a conventional scan or biopsy and, you know, then proceed with whatever the results give you proceed with, you know, whatever you think might be the best course of action.
Next question, I have increasing pain in the chest, sternum and radiating out from there to muscles in the chest and back and armpits for four months, my PCP recommends a chest x-ray, is this a wise thing to do.
So kind of along the same lines as the previous question, we cannot tell any of our patients to have any conventional scans, we really have to stay in our lane.
You know, it's hard people are looking for us to give wisdom and provide that, you know, answers, but really we have to be very strict with this and stick in our lane, you know, we are here for right therapies, we're here to support you with diet to nutrition, you know, with prayer and ultimately your care is in your hands.
So you need to be the one making the decisions on on what you're doing.
As far as anything conventional so we encourage patients to pray we encourage patients to obviously yes way the pros and cons, you know, and if the results of a conventional scan would sway your decision on your care and potentially make it so that you might get conventional care then.
You know, certainly by all means get a conventional test done as far as pain is involved, you know, a chest x-ray for pain, you know, I don't know if if pain is kind of the the thing that we're trying to address here if an x-ray would be necessary to just help with pain.
Obviously to see what the cause of the pain would be so certainly you can do it if you would like to know more details on people need to know the details for peace of mind and so conventional scans and tests can be a great way to get that piece of mind.
So, you know, and for pain doctor Connors has done a lot of videos on pain, there is a video that is called good pain bad pain I know it's on our blog on our regular website i'm sure it's posted on the patient membership site as well as a video so you can just search for that good pain bad pain and it kind of walks through some of the.
You know, reasons why we have pain and can kind of put your mind at ease as to what your pain might be from you know he goes through us pain can be because of tumor growth.
Obviously we don't want that and so things you know we might need to do some retesting with the cheek swab to see if we need to change anything with your protocol.
You know there are certain things that you can do supplements you can take to help decrease inflammation that can help with pain so it goes through specific supplements coffee enemas can be really helpful for pain and you know multiple coffee enemas in one day the more pain that you have they say the more coffee enemas you should do so five or six coffee enemas a day if your pain is really bad that helps to stimulate the vagus nerve.
Which helps reduce the sensation of pain so pain is one thing figuring out the reason why the pain is happening and then dealing and managing the pain.
Because if pain is good you know pain can be because of a therapy that we're doing you know right therapy can cause some pain we're sending the immune system to.
Those cancer cells we're attacking those cancer cells we're hoping that those cells are dying that die off process can cause some pain certainly in for inflammation and swelling and so.
If therapy has just started you know you know and the pain is localized to the cancer site specifically typically we look at that as more of a good pain.
Versus a tumor growth bad pain he goes over in this video referred pain as well so pain that can be just referred you know you might have shoulder pain that's not due to anything wrong in the shoulder but could be from.
Something along the cervical spine or you know could be from liver gallbladder so he goes through a number of these scenarios and then things that you can do to help with pain so I encourage everybody to watch that if you're wondering about pain it's a very common question that we get and it is scary pain can be scary we automatically with cancer diagnosis tend to jump to the conclusion that.
Tumors are growing if there's pain and yes that can be the case but it's not always the case especially when there's other therapies involved so certainly watch that video it's a good one and there's probably a number of other videos on pain as well so I encourage you to.
I encourage you to do a search for that we are planning a vacation and would like to take our coffee animal supplies with us have you any experience with making a concentrated coffee to bring and just add clean water when we use it there yes absolutely you can do that.
Many people do that make it just a concentrated version so they're not having to make up the coffee every single day and then they're just adding water to it to dilute it before the animal so that's perfectly fine.
I have been taking a product from a company that is a NRF2 activator and they just came out with a college and that increases SOD 27 times and blood catalyst level increases 202% would this be helpful for breast cancer.
So NRF2 SOD catalysts these are all antioxidants that can help of course with reactive oxygen species so can neutralize those free radicals free radicals can cause tissue damage and certainly can be a cause for cancer cellular damage so NRF2 SOD and catalysts are all genetic pathways that we look at.
The person that submitted this question I do not believe their genetics have come back yet so we certainly could dig deeper into this when we have that information back but that being said SOD and catalysts are absolutely fine to take they certainly could be helpful with a breast cancer diagnosis that could be helpful with with any cancer diagnosis.
So yeah I don't see the harm in taking that and then we can look further at genetics and see you know you might have some defects and SOD and catalysts that promote different free radicals and so could be helpful.
Alright next question I have been learning a bit about greens powders and wondered what the clinics thoughts are on powders with grasses in them like wheat and barley it's hard to find powders without them without them in them I would like to stay away from the lectins if I can and or should so.
With so certainly when we think of wheat and we think of barley yes those contain gluten those are grains so gluten is part of the grain so the seed or the root of those wheat and barley but what is in the greens powders are certainly at least with our greens powder our greens first is wheat grass and barley grass.
That is different it is not the seed or the root and so they do not contain gluten wheat grass barley grass does not contain gluten therefore does not contain the lectins so you want to make sure you're using you know a reputable company for your greens product because if the grasses are not harvested properly they could contain some of those seeds and roots therefore not to be.
You know gluten free or lectin free so certainly you want to watch for that but the greens first powder does not contain gluten because it is again the wheat grass and barley grass and we certainly encourage greens powders it's typically part of most of our patients protocol here the greens first.
Alright the next question another histamine question by leftovers does that mean any leftovers or what is what is the time period that is considered okay a day or two maybe what about meat in an ideal situation what is best to do that is the last histamine this person has to eliminate so.
So yeah so leftovers anytime food is left sitting you know obviously in the refrigerator but it is going to start to break down that process does create histamine so I would say you would probably want to consume your leftovers within about a 24 hour timeframe if you're not going to eat it within that 24 hour timeframe freeze it and then you can freeze it in you know individual portion so you can easily kind of reheat warm it up.
And then that would be that would be okay so about 24 hours.
And nice work the it's hard to eliminate a lot of those histamine high histamine foods so so good job on that do you have a protein powder that you recommend or should I stay away from them I would like to have one possible in case I'm traveling and can't get clean food or is the food better in my situation so certainly you can do a protein powder.
We do have a couple different protein powders that we recommend for cancer patients available on our web store they're by US enzymes so there is a chocolate version or there is a vanilla version it's just called protein signs protein xym and it's a vegan protein so there's no dairy in it does it does contain some digestive enzymes so it is going to help.
You know process foods does contain some super foods in there so you can take a look at that if I am doing the rebounder for 15 minutes plus a day what I benefit from dry brushing also or is that overkill you certainly can benefit from both of them and I do not think it is overkill so if you're doing the rebounder for 15 plus minutes you know in the morning then I would just say maybe you do your dry brushing.
In the evening so separate them out a little bit and yeah just continuing to work on movement of that lymph getting rid of that waste and processing that is great so it's not overkill.
Dr. V referenced a study that found reaching mushroom should be avoided by people with hormone positive cancers since that is me and the reaching mushrooms are in the addition medicinal mushrooms I am wondering about that also is there a risky free version available i'm going to defer this question to Dr Connors I don't know of the specific study that you are referencing and I am not aware of this link.
But certainly could be a possible absolutely so a lot of times when patients are tested you know with our kinesiology doing our testing you know it might be a product that they thought oh I you know maybe you shouldn't have this or I read a study about about that and but certainly with testing.
There is most likely a component in that product obviously that is helping balance cancer for you so you know we kind of stick to our recommendations based on our testing and it might be that maybe you need you know specific nutrient for certain from that product for certain amount of time and it could change so not saying that you have to be on it forever.
But I will pass on this question to Dr Connors and for the Wednesday Zoom call maybe you can dig a little deeper into this particular study and the link between reaching mushrooms and hormone positive cancers I just received a voicemail from this person's provider saying that they want to get her on a schedule for fine needle aspiration.
She looked it up and that is a biopsy not sure that is good does that spread cancer they're going to call within the hours so she's wondering what to do and then kind of another issue when she met with a hematologist study would possibly prescribe iron he said he would test for iron and vitamin B 12 so okay.
So talking about a biopsy so we kind of just briefly spoke about this and again it falls into the category of us legally and ethically not being able to answer this question and tell you what you should do so I do apologize I know it is so hard and you're trying to make the best decision and you're looking to us for guidance and.
Unfortunately again just legally and ethically we cannot answer that and we have had to become a lot more strict in that and trying to stay in our lane of natural health and not making conventional.
You know recommendations so we can't answer that but certainly we encourage you to do what you feel is best to use prayer sometimes when we're we're faced with a decision and we feel the pressure from the conventional side I think that's the biggest thing is they.
They feel like they need to answer right away so allow yourself time there's nobody forcing your hand on all of this so.
If you don't feel comfortable making a decision because you haven't had time to grapple with it to pray about it to have peace about it then.
You need to do that so take the time that you need to do that and then when you are ready you can let the doctor know what your decision is and then you will be ready you can.
You know approach that therapy with with peace and with confidence and so that's what you need and what you need to do regarding B12 and iron low hemoglobin so certainly we need to kind of look at.
At labs doctor Connors can evaluate labs and obviously iron can feed cancer many patients struggle with low iron and so it's kind of a predicament what do we do we don't want to give iron because iron can feed cancer but.
The symptoms and effects of low iron on the body are not obviously desirable as well and need to be addressed so.
Depending on where you're at you know we can try to do things we have our iron are to miss an in protocol.
If we need to implement that implement that we can you know there's foods that are high in iron vitamin C also helps with iron absorption and then with the combination of the art of missing in.
Then taking that about an hour after you're taking an iron supplement are to miss an art of missing and we'll piggyback with that iron and so if the cancer cells are up taking some of that iron they're also getting the art of missing in which you know the goal is to then that's a cancer fighter so destroy those cancer cells with the art of missing in.
So that would be you know maybe a first line approach and if that doesn't help and a patient's hemoglobin drops to that point where okay we we need to make some decisions here an iron transfusion might be recommended and certainly if if that is the scenario you're in.
Then you know that's most likely what you will need to do and Dr Connors has talked about the difference between taking iron orally and getting an infusion and it doesn't quite affect the cancer cells the same way so if you're doing an iron infusion you don't have to.
You know worry that oh my gosh i'm just totally feeding the cancer cells here it's processed differently and so.
So you know you can feel confident in and just knowing that okay your iron is that low you do need to get that infusion but we'll try everything that we can from a natural and all perspective to increase that iron certainly be vitamin B12 plays a role.
And you can you can supplement with B12 but we do want to make sure it's in the right form we don't want methylated versions of B12 and okay next question i noticed in the last week or so that the lump on my net continues to grow on as much larger so experiencing stabbing pains in that area.
Sleep is being hard disruptive to sleep the growth is causing the area to impinge on nerves and so the neck is affected so a lot of pain and discomfort first i thought it was because of the right machine and the protocol we were working and that my body was fighting the cancer thus causing additional inflammation in that area but now I don't know.
And i'm scared because i'm in a lot of pain and unable to sleep and get my rest so yes absolutely a vicious vicious cycle there.
When I get up and move around it seems to help alleviate the pain but it feels tight and there remains a dull pain at this point i'm at a loss and I don't know what to do so I wanted to reach out with any suggestions you might have.
So again referring you to that good pain bad pain video it's a great video that I think we'll put your mind at ease so yes can be related to growth to my growth but in this case because we're kind of early in the in the process here we're we're beginning you know with the right and all of the supplements and the therapies so I do think that this particular person's pain.
is most likely associated with the cancer therapy still obviously yes very scary and maybe you know just the nerves in the skin itself when the tumor is that close to the surface and kind of stretching the skin that can cause a lot of pain.
So things that we can do to help alleviate the pain you know you can do ice packs we can do anti inflammatory supplements that doctor counters goes through in that video.
Curcue clear is one of those clear and slam is a great supplement just a lot of different herbs synergistic blend of things to help combat inflammation.
CBD THC so THC is probably going to be the strongest natural thing that can reduce pain certainly some therapies tens units can you know decrease pain sensation I mentioned coffee animals earlier so certainly coffee animals you know I don't I can't remember if this person is doing coffee animals or not but can try those and then you know multiple in a day.
To stimulate that biggest nerve and everyone's binder there's a list of biggest nerve exercises and so get familiar with those and so if there is some pain.
Some of those things can be really helpful a lot of those things on that list they may seem little silly like you know gargling and singing but certainly they can help with pain.
And again this person in particular I do think that it is associated with the therapies and not tumor growth of course we can't say that for sure but we have to just way the scenario you know kind of look at other things that might be going on.
And kind of gauge and then certainly with the passage of time you know is this continuing is this intermittent you know we can we can gauge as well but check out that video on pain okay let's see here.
So this person has breast cancer she's doing the black sub topical so she is letting us know that the the asher fell off so she reapplied the sub to the entire open wound on July 1st the pain was intense.
But has since subsided and less frequent I've noticed more pain is falling in in her armpit tightness and the left arm seems to come and go.
The entire left breast is very hard and tender how do I know if I should treat other areas of my breast or should I expect that the black staff will draw it all towards the existing wound.
So certainly with the black staff there needs to be pretty close or direct contact to the cancer cells themselves by an open wound in order for it to have an effect so if you put it on another part of your breast that doesn't have kind of that director very close to the surface of the skin exposure there.
It's likely wouldn't be any reaction at all so I would just continue to put the black staff on the wound itself and yes the goal of that is that it is drawing it is drawing it from other parts of the body that's probably why you feel the sensation and tightness in your arm the area is tender and hard.
That is the reaction of the black staff and so I would just continue to putting it on to apply that to the existing open wound alright my husband is having fluid build up in his lungs from his lung cancer are there some recommendations to help with reducing and improving.
reducing the influence excuse me the fluid and improving the breathing so yes there are some things that you can do with the right machine so everybody in their binder has these pages here it's a list of I don't even know probably 15 pages for right programs for symptoms.
So look at these so anybody you know we've talked a lot about pain so anybody who is experiencing pain these programs can help alleviate some pain pain bio one pain bio to muscle pain and tightness anything to reduce inflammation can help with pain as well so you have the right so use this tool to help with your symptoms so pain go through that there's more listed than just these here.
So you can run any of these programs and see if they help to alleviate some of your pain specifically for fluid build up a demon or a sighties these are programs that you can run so I would definitely try those here's right frequencies for swelling as well you can try these as well.
For this specific scenario and many times with the sighties you do need to get the fluid drained in order to alleviate the symptoms so shortness of breath inability to you know take a deep breath is can be alleviated by getting the fluid drained so that that might be necessary.
And can provide immediate relief but certainly these things can help so I would try these things and and go from there.
Let's see I think we've got we've gotten through the questions that came in so i'll open up the chat here and see okay.
The type of mushrooms that are in the miracle mix one i have two other bottles of mushrooms I want to stop doubling up on supplements due to cost so I don't know the list of all the mushrooms that are in the miracle mix number one but you can go to our web store.
And just type in miracle mix number one and the list is there there's probably about 10 different mushrooms it is a blend so you can look that up and then yeah you can compare with the supplements that you currently are taking and kind of eliminate yes that can get get costly so yeah so do that.
Okay next question here i've heard a lot about halin and wonder and i'm wondering about adding this to my protocol do you do test me to see if this would be good for me so yes so halin 951 is a product that many of our breast cancer patients take we do test patients for it so if we have not put you on it it is most likely because it did not.
Test as being necessary at least for now, but what this product does is it helps to dislodge.
The dirty estrogens that are blocking the receptor sites the hormone receptor sites on the cancer cells and this is beneficial because if if those dirty estrogens are blocking those sites it's blocking apoptosis of those cancer cells so we want to.
to dislodge the dirty estrogens and that's what the halin 951 does to allow for other things to bind to the receptor sites you know like vitamin D can bind to that receptor site once it's cleared out of that dirty estrogen vitamin D can bind to it stimulate apoptosis of those cells.
So if we have it i'll check and see if we did test you on it and we can kind of follow up with that but yes we do test patients for it.
let's see i am taking essay act pills ip6 gold pills dandelion pills are to miss my pills to help kill the cancer can you tell me how many pills I should be taking of each so I can't tell you directly without looking at your protocol so you can send me an email and to remind me and we can.
look at this so if it's something that we have recommended obviously we will have a dose for you if it's something that we have not recommended and you are just taking them because you would like to add them to your protocol then we typically would just have you follow the directions on the label but I can follow up with you on that.
But I was diagnosed with stomach cancer I have whoops that just shifted okay I was diagnosed with stomach cancer I have weak blood vessels and nitric oxide was suggested please help me understand the effects of nitric oxide are there any other alternatives i'm praying for something to help with that and I also have low red blood cells so yeah so sometimes.
It is you know kind of something that you we need to weigh the pros and cons on something that might be good for general health reasons maybe are not so good for cancer reasons so it is kind of a fine line and we have to weigh that and certainly if you decide to take something.
that maybe isn't so great for cancer you know maybe we can test and you know implement some more cancer balancing or cancer fighting things but specifically for nitric oxide and the reason that we hesitate with anything that promotes nitric oxide is because of what it does to the blood vessels it relaxes the blood vessels and so it.
It can encourage blood flow which can be a great thing for the cardiovascular system but it is not so great for cancer because anything that is going to encourage blood flow can encourage blood flow to cancer cells and so we just need to try to manage that so there are.
Some other things you know that we can do to kind of help encourage low red blood cells and you know we can I can specifically follow up with this person to kind of make maybe some recommendations you know I know you're already taking some B12 you're taking the right form of that so that is.
is great maybe we need to look at some food sources so i'll follow up with you specifically but yes in general we don't want patients taking a supplement form of anything that is going to encourage nitric oxide production.
Let's see I missed the first couple minutes is this a new Q&A in addition to the Wednesday yes it is a new Q&A so every Monday at noon I will be doing this Q&A session.
And Dr Connors is still obviously doing the Wednesday at 4 o'clock so hopefully this will be a benefit to everyone and we can get some additional questions answered and as I did in this zoom call if I'm not sure I don't know where I feel like it would be better answered by Dr Connors i'll pass it on pass a question on to him so he can address it let's see.
I sent in a cheek swab last Wednesday haven't received the results yet I have asked about taking Artemis and in at least three times and it's never been recommended is it a K tested yes so it can be a K tested and you know we can you know patients can take it where if they're doing the iron Artemis and protocol you know it doesn't necessarily need to be tested for if iron is low and.
You know we're going to try to attack it because it's at that point then we can we can implement that but we do we can test for it and if we haven't.
And you did send in a cheek swab then I am assuming that we will be getting that swab soon and we can definitely test for it and make specific recommendations.
What exactly are cancer or excuse me what exactly are balancers so balancers are something to balance cancer so in our testing you know we're looking to determine cause we're looking to determine specific cancer balancers for each individual so that is specific supplements that are targeted to.
To balance cancer or fight your cancer specifically so there's hundreds of nutraceuticals that you know can be great for fighting cancer or have anti cancer properties but that doesn't mean that everyone should take all of those things because.
Everyone is different and one thing might be working to fight somebody's cancer and they might have the same diagnosis as another person but it's not working for that other person so our testing is specific on what is coming up as the balancer for every individual person's cancer so that's that's part of what we're testing and so our protocol.
You know includes those cancer balancers for you and it's listed as you know either cancer fighting supplements or cancer balancing supplements so if you look in your binder in your AK results page that everybody should have it should list cancer balancers and those are your specific cancer balancers and obviously those change with subsequent testing.
And so you might you know that might change with subsequent testing.
All right that seems to be all of the questions that came in on the chat and all that came in through the zoom question format whoops maybe just got one more let's see.
Oh you're welcome I look forward to hearing if there are other options I assume you will send me an email my hands and feet are tingly and cold yes that can be yes low nitric oxide so that can decrease circulation.
I do take a raw beef each day so that's that's fine so that's you know food form so that's fine so yes I will reach out to you via email and see if there's anything else that we can.
Do other than taking that supplement that you sent me so all right everyone will hopefully this was helpful and just I encourage everybody to use you know use the blog use the membership site search your questions out.
Dr. Connors puts a lot of time and effort into kind of creating these videos and so any question that you have you know just key it into that search bar of their their most likely as a as a video to help you understand your question and thank you for submitting your questions.
It's good it's good to have everybody here these answers even though obviously I know you know you're listening to other people's questions but it's good to learn it's good to you know it might be something that helps you in in the future or it might answer a question that you didn't even know that you had.
So we look forward to these opportunities to help educate and guide you guys we are praying for each and every one of you.
You know I know a lot of questions cannot be answered by us but we just encourage you to you know turn to God turn to prayer turn to what makes the most sense for you what feels right for you what gives you peace and we will walk alongside you with whatever decision that you are going to make know that we have protocols designed to help with conventional with conventional.
therapies or scans or things that you're doing so just keep us in the loop with everything and know that we are praying for you guys have a wonderful rest of your Monday Dr. Connors of course we'll be back on on Wednesday at 4 p.m. Central time.
All right to you guys have a good day bye bye.